welcome to this video for around 12 of
the candidate candidates tournament in
cantonment disc russia and this is about
the game mamedyarov playing white
against kayaking playing black which
means both players on fifty percent and
in order to get some sort of chance to
catch the tournament leader former world
champion vigilant they need to ever
winner in the game which yeah pretty
much show us some or a pretty much
indicate that we get a sharp game let's
see what happens yeah we got the news oh
and Mama dro plays f3 the line that he
already had used successfully to beat
level aronian in a crucial game just a
couple of days ago okay I can however
place another line castles was erroneous
choice he plan to move c5 which made me
curious because I'm as probably lots of
you know I'm writing a book it takes a
long while because I have some other
obligations like a doing all those
videos and the book is about a black
repertoire in the namazu alien and the
bogo Indian and in the names of Indian
part i'm recommending exactly the line
that coyoacán is playing here is playing
this this very aggressive continuation
with b5 which immediately at x white
center the best continuation is here
efore plate also by Mammadyarov and now
the big point of blacks players to
Castle not to play like they did inform
years where black was capturing here and
try to get an equal position in this way
looks quite funny but this is actually
very good for black
y term he needs to take with the bishop
but after ed Queen takes black is
slightly slightly under pressure so not
too great but my own recommended move
with Sir castles I mean I didn't invent
it there were examples of this but I
decided that this should be a good way
to to play it's very sharp after five
black needs to drop back the night we
ate looks a bit crazy but this nigel we
get will get back into the game White
has a very extended Center and not much
development yeah f for this is pretty
much necessary to to give some support
to the center I always thought that this
is a very funny line where white moves
her out of eight initial movie he plays
seven pawn moves and just has the knight
on c3 which is already already pinned
well in the meantime black has castled
and put the night on yet looks really
strange but and this is of course a very
hyper modern approach which basically
means that like is conceding the center
initially but now will do everything in
order to destroy it night of three I'm
sorry black first that took here 26 yep
93 NT a plate c4 yeah here's the
difference to my repertoire suggestion
um the only thing I'm going to tell
right now you still need to get the book
released then my choice is 97 which is
also exceptionally sharp I mean if you
had followed recent games you might have
seen the really great game between the
Brazilian grandmas Alexander fear and
Micky Adams from the Gibraltar open
where they had the super sharp game in
this line maybe you can look it up on
chess games com
or just google the garage open 2014 best
games or something you know this would
pop up very sharp as well ya see 4mm was
kayaking choice it auto makes lots of
sense this kind of push it has various
ideas one idea is simply to protect the
ball on b5 of course it is not detect
any more by the bishop now and very
often you can get a Bishop to c5 or
queen to be 6 that actually helps white
helps to disturb White's development and
castling it's still very sharp of course
after a four black has a hard time to
protect this interior gives the porn up
actually and tries to speed up its
development I want to do any bigger
alternative see I can only mention that
here the original game of this line was
played with Bishop g4 this was actually
played by chrome neck as black against
Alex a sheer off in Shanghai 2010 and
they'd led to it led to enormous
complications or and it seems to be okay
for black but sheer off gotta got a good
position with very very strong play um
in my analysis I think I came to the
conclusion that this is playable for
black but it is a very very hairy
business so the same 97 them I think
it's also quite interesting there should
be two Red Queen to be 6 yeah white snow
takes and black place 927 he needs to
use the night on the aid of course to
get some development going Bishop d7 is
coming next to get to the get the d5
pawn and yet some very concrete already
white needs to do something to get
castled and you cannot stay here all the
time with the King in after Bishop d7 95
your video will be a ruby attack iam so
Normandy event for Queen to d4 which is
a good move
I believe um Bishop to be seven was
played no Bishop to d2 yeah making sure
that this pin is broken um ya know black
took on c3 and Dwight recaptured with
the pawn which is quite surprising I
believe I mean I really would have
thought that Bishop takes you three
years like like the absolutely normal
move and it seems that this should be
about equal it's a complicated position
nevertheless a possible line just to
give you an idea it's not meant as a
thorough analysis a possible line could
be on the de Fe and maybe 95 trying to
get the bishop which might be one of the
reasons why Mammadyarov didn't play that
he probably didn't want to give up the
bishop I yet um it's probably around
equal to serve this position we do a
quick count here and white is got five
pawns blacks got five pots we've got
equal material but all those pawns here
are quite weak and can easily fall in
the upcoming complications let's say
just just to illustrate something like
that can easily lead to further
exchanges where at the end term will get
the situation assembly it's not much
left on the board um this pthc move that
Normandy are of play dismay be
objectively weaker here but it keeps
more tension in the position simply
because any capture on d4 now can be
answered by seat XD for so right here
for example and this seems to me quite
okay for white let's say here Dwight has
got the initial additional idea rook a
42 to get this back just a one
possibility um the trade on d4 is really
less attractive now as what can take
with the pawn but kayak and simply
took the material in the center and took
on d5 so the white center is basically
collapsing you see worse I don't know it
it this might be but it's not an
entirely entirely clear fair he now
wrapped even the b5 pawn seems okay and
and castles yeah White's idea is simply
after 96 queen age for this was played
is simply to transfer all the pieces for
King cytotec black has a very solid King
side in terms of pawn structure there's
no weakness now like h 6o g six which
would invite sacrifices on or direct
attacks but why potentially can bring
many pieces they are like this is a
typical idea getting the bishop on this
attractive diagonal this always night
jumps and yeah in general the position
is very much open f-fine open a file and
open so white has enormous piece
activity and the situation is not
entirely clear um the next move back a
are keen is really ambitious and frankly
a bit risky um I thought that probably a
five is a good alternative just I mean a
five the a point is you're winning poem
if if anything so it's probably an idea
to push it what the kayaking did was
even more ambitious he played NAT D to C
5 in order to put this night on b3 and
then push the apron so that the night is
actually supporting the final queening
of the a porn it's it's like a it's like
investing two moves to to to to up the
ante sew to save if black delivers this
touchdown on a one that will really win
but it takes time and it transfers a
piece to be three which is not exactly a
spot way to defense the the king so one
I don't know I really think a five could
be could be a good alternative but it's
very tricky or very complicate
to to analyze this early one possible
setup is by the way to put the Queen on
c6 year which makes lots of sense it
increases this pressure on the long
diagonal and is also ready to sometimes
swing over to the kingside to defend
this in fact looks like pretty decent
setup rupee one is maybe also not the
best movement it's very hard as
mentioned to do a thorough analysis
another point by the way is that the ID
form might be answered by queen bee to
taking here so this was probably a good
way to play Janna dc5 was played and now
after be one night b3 this was the plan
Mammadyarov went for Bishop to d1 and
initiates the mentioned transfer of the
bishop to see to to really get some
attack going and the position now will
become extremely technical it starts
right here um ki can plate queen to a 5
which looks a bit illogical as I
mentioned that the apron so when did you
win a pony would you block it that's
true but the thing is you need to really
very completely calculate variations now
and this is a technics III and gets the
Queen involved into the game really it
seems to be a good move black could do
other things he could have taken on f3
for example this is one thing that I
looked at simply to get rid of this
attacking night rook takes and Queenie 5
just grabbing everything um this
probably will lead to a draw group h 3 h
6 and our bishop c2 yet here white a
threatening the brutal Bishop takes h6
and black it probably must plane a g5
here to stop that and this is
not that it Queen takes oops this is
further chanical draw check and turn I'm
black click and try to avoid 95 but it
is not easy to do if you take here for
example white book play Bishop 24 and to
continue to attack yeah now I'm 95 is
obviously no draw anymore and it gets
very very tricky now f5 bishop d fire
for example sets up an enormous pin um I
don't know like probably shouldn't risk
that but Bishop e3 it's it seemed it
seemed playable it simply were probably
not the best move but it was played on
um what happens if black ignores all
that and plays a 5 yeah then you get
Bishop g2 in and it's not so clear what
blacks counterplay exactly is if you
look at this g6 em well h6 is completely
out of the question you can just smash
on h6 so g6 and of course yeah the dark
squares I immensely week which is really
as something that happens to you quite
yeah not frequently this is would be
wrong but if you play the NIMS oh you
very often give up your dark squared
bishop of course to capturing on c3 and
it is some something to always be aware
of that you're lacking this bishop and
it defends with g6 it's very often
giving up your dark squares and leading
to to some problems here 95 is
exceptionally strong like mistake of
course Bishop takes yeah and now we get
get a very a similar teching pattern
like to the game but blacks queen is not
really helping much in defending it
would be good simply to look at the game
and compare this so keep in mind this
position with the Queen being somewhere
off-site here in comparison to the game
continued
I think white as a so such a strong
attack here it would probably win Queen
a five and now we get this yeah see it's
very very similar takes takes and now in
this position kayaking took on c3 and
this was the point of Queen 85 and it's
not like he wants to grab a porn yes
it's nice to to get another pawn but the
main point is that the queen is helping
in defense it can sometimes just take
the important d5 pawn it can also in
some cases give a check here if the
bishop is coming to f6 so this is a
queen at five-twenty xe3 was a mostly a
defensive maneuver yeah here Nora of
played rook f2 which seems fine there's
also this constant counter play against
g2 that can be an issue for example if
you would have played Bishop f6 that's
the problem you need to do something
about the bishop and basically I think
there were two moves yet for white the
one he played Luke f2 or rugby to d1 was
also an interesting move and the idea is
simply the counter-attack against the
bishop so that now we take C 2 is
answered by rock d5 and this is in fact
a totally winning position which might
not occur to you at first sight but the
check with Bishop f6 or Bishop h 6 years
really decisive black has no no serious
counter play but it's no problem after
rookie one black does not need to take
here on c2 of course you can play a
bishop c6 and after that probably rook
f2 with the right move and this actually
transposes some and transposase sir to
almost almost transposes sir two to the
game um let's check you know exactly now
95 two is six this is the defensive
maneuver yeah I have so many lines now
in the upcoming move that it's really
confusing in my notes yeah 95 to get to
e6 cover the the mate square hunt 1 g7
and this obviously is very dangerous for
black but I couldn't really find find
something something decisive him Bishop
f6 looks very natural or bill 96 and how
exactly do you make like now queen age
six and now black needs to find a good
move but rook 88 is the best simply
ignoring the fact that white can take on
the edge with this word to give up the
all-important bishop yeah it gets very
deep discern and then is this why
probably should take and now drop the
Queen back into the game it's a it's an
interesting position but very hard to
evaluate like has got two pawns for the
exchange and has got pretty solid
positions form for the pieces I think
black should be fine here it's nothing
to to really be afraid of he can also go
here possibly intending to drop the
Queen back to one of those good
defensive squares it's all so I'm very
important to note that lots of end games
with them in exchange down here could be
drawn because of whites slightly
compromised pawn structure for example
an end game with two rooks against rook
and Bishop with the bishop only six is
probably a draw um
we get to such a position later so back
to the initial game position this is
what was quite a quite a long line Luke
f2s mansion was played and now night
deform yeah it's a it's getting to a
toaster a comparable position 94 and now
Bishop to h6 yeah obviously white thread
is Queen to f6 and black has two ways
now to deal with that first of all what
about this move Bishop h6 Bishop f6
sorry this was of course possible black
can't play Queen III or 96 96 can easily
lead to positions that we had seen
before for example rookie one pushup c6
and we transpose that we had already
seen before note that white cannot do it
in a very direct fashion now let's say
look here for example like move this
look away to get a square you cannot do
it like that urn I'm hoping for stuff
like we need to check check check mate
yeah this would be neat but in reality
like it's not going to allow that after
rook takes you can for example play the
simple move Queen d2 and now check your
dream says stop right here White has an
attack but it's not it's not a decisive
it's just probably enough to compensate
for the two pawns he's got to pawn
sacrifice already he played Bishop to h6
it's probably even the more dangerous
move I'm kayaking responded with knight
c6 he also had 96 the sir I think was
possible again setting up this night
only six to cover g7 um
it's a it's tough to save it's so
complicated Queen have six probably and
of course you only need to somehow get
rid of your of this night only six and
your mating black but how exactly I
going to do that I really don't don't
see away and by the way this can be
considered but now blacks position is
very much he has improved in terms of
King side safety and I really didn't
like that for what you should try to
continue with with you attack with with
queen of six yeah 196 wasn't played he
played knight c6 and this is a different
defensive concept he just wants to take
a five this is important attacking
attacking unit it's not just just a corn
it supports those jumps to have six yeah
well knight c6 and what did why play now
I played rook to d1 taking the the
bishop here an alternative here was
Bishop to a four um this is one of the
the most solid ways to try it for what
what happens now if black takes here
this is a very annoying move Queen as
noted square to go this does not really
help all nighter basically em cannot
take on e5 and align possible is Queenie
five and now for example this
this could happen and position like that
with Bishop d7 coming to e6 is
completely dead in terms of whites
winning chances black has absolutely no
virus here it's quite funny that that
some engines give right little hunter to
this position because well this is the
type of the type of setup even after the
Queen trade they say why should be
slightly better this is the kind of
position where well as black you can can
even play against cards that you won't
lose because it's a total fortress King
on g7 and you just stay nothing happens
um okay it didn't happen there should be
a form they both really have tried to
play in the in the most principled
aggressive way possible and not going
for any any direct draws Mammadyarov
played rook t1 attacking this bishop and
you need to know that kayak ins clock
time was going down rapidly he was in
huge tribe trouble already this was this
clock term here on shown on the screen
is a bit too high I think and he was a
far far lower in just a couple of months
okay he took only five which was the
idea all along and now mama gaea of
plays a quite a quite a shocking
attacking move look at five it's a it's
quite quite hard to believe all this but
it would happened note that again white
could consider to capture but after that
it's not helping your attack Black has
three pawns for the exchange already and
this is simply too good an attacking
unit look at five is a an attractive
move anyway if you're spotted you should
play it and the thing is that black now
could have taken on f5 which would have
lead to a draw mayara was forced to play
we got five basically you didn't have
any
other taking a device left after that
why draws with rook takes d5 funny
enough and now after the Queen check
here rook t125 we will have a perpetual
there is no way to avoid it this is
quite funny black cam does not have any
other checks so let's say Quincy is free
for argument's sake then white just oops
takes on f5 and this is the decisive
attack with Bishop takes h7 being the
threat yeah just to show the general
idea of black plays any any sort of move
I don't know which one is this one maybe
just just to show it he takes and yes
and wide wins of course not only the
Queen this will also be a checkmate
against the king which means that after
this this funny move oops sorry takes
rook t5 it will be at all but kayaking
wanted to win the game despite being a
being a download time I mean he's got
three extra pawns so he's got some
course for her for trying ok he played
Queen to e7 of course this is risky but
no doubt about that Queen to e7 em so
Bishop g5 obviously what else and now he
played the move f6 which is probably the
best choice um they're only is Quincy
five to check as an alternative of
course you're attacked on d5 twice you
need to play something with the tempo we
cannot play slow move here um king edge
one for example and then night before
this was the only alternative that you
could consider but it it is very very
dangerous after Bishop before I know
it's a completely wild position but this
was the only halfway playable
alternative but it seems to be too
dangerous for black the move f6 that
kayak and played is also in a way very
typical as you this way get a little bit
of room for
the king and and in a way slow down the
attack for just for just one move um now
our jar of took on d5 with the rook yeah
was there something else yeah he could
have taken on f6 with the bishop and
this is a very tough position now black
probably must check he does not really
have anything else you need to check to
get this temple yeah and now this rook
is hanging what is going to retreat now
yet here you can examine various moves
um probably the best move is rook 88
which after a possible line of rook
takes d5 night before note that so
that's a double attack um could lead to
the following Queen here I 25 25 rupee 6
and now Queen to be three it's probably
a necessary move it's all very
complicated i'm sorry if i'm doing this
somewhat too quick but if i'm going
through through everything here I've got
it to our video on my ins it's um it's
just a super tactical game okay what I'm
getting at is that this is probably the
result of all that and i think this this
actually should be should be a draw in
the end which is not agreed which is not
confirmed by by the computer but i don't
really see how white should should win
this position it looks really nice with
the bishops but you're in a sort of pin
here on the f file and if you need if
you exchange one pair of rooks you're
never going to win so i don't see how
white should avoid that you can try
various things here like this for
example try to check rugae three
let's say Bishop eform again trying this
and then I'm moving the the pawn yeah
let's say h5 point being that Bishop g6
Luke a6 is not ending well for white and
black will probably just put the King
here and intense Luke a six at the right
moment to force a rook trade and after
that three white is not going to win
ever very long line and I'm not saying
that it is necessarily or completely
forced but Bishop f6 I think would have
given white quite substantial challenges
to win especially considering that ki
can had very little time on the clock by
the way queen III check rook f2 there's
also the move Bishop to f7 trying to to
to cover up the the King side note that
the queen is protecting the h6 square
and this can also need to very tricky
play Rukia Bishop b4 for example
intending this night attend to take the
night and the night really has a problem
if if it moves let's say let's say here
for example what can just take the rook
and if black takes takes us rook to
cover the night then white has the very
strong idea coming up to play Bishop to
a1 and Queen to f6 it's a very very
dangerous position for black Bishop f6
was probably in a practical sense maybe
it would have decided the game it's hard
to tell k yakin had really very little
time I think he'd less than this one
minute 44 and very doubtful if he could
have defended that okay he took here it
takes on g5 and Quincy for of course
this is also looking very attractive for
what getting the porn back and one porn
back still two points down and the while
blacks King is open so it looks still
very dangerous Queen to e6
eight this should be three yeah this is
an enormous diagonal black needs to get
the king of all of that and now Queen to
c5 um here white also could have played
Queen City which after Queen f6 check
leads to something quite comparable to
the main game at the end with pretty
good drawing chances of relief for what
look at the game that will look familiar
Quincy five was played and they both had
a little time but Kuryakin was down two
seconds really two seconds probably even
less than what is shown iam Quincy five
now Brooke 88 yeah a very logical move
typical time trial move also getting a
big threat in yourself you like to play
those kind of forcing moves um yeah I TM
mamedyarov plate yeah most the most
aggressive move possibly played H for
which of course addresses this may
threat by giving the king of light
square on h2 on h2 and it puts the
maximum pressure on black yeah here in
fact maybe this is pure theory because
kayaking had seconds on the clock it
seems that you could have actually taken
on h4 instead of this check if it takes
we can look at that this looks a very
dangerous initially because of Bishop a4
with a with a pin but this is still
quite okay for black you can play look
at six and now it's remarkable and enter
quite typical of some things that the
computer will show you which is
completely irrelevant for practical game
of chess YTM in fact has only one way
two draws free porns down but he can
draw with roughly seven which looks
hello I not sure what what to call it it
looks totally weird to put the rook
right inside your pin that you just
build up but it's it's a good move the
idea is that white is just intends to
take twice on c6 then take on a seven
and then go with both rooks on the
seventh and draw that's really happening
if for instance Queen III just start to
show it this is a dead wrong look cam
studi seven and those two looks will
guarantee you a perpetual the toughest
move seems to be not the the rook the
Queen a check but Queenie five after
which only funny enough Quincy one seems
to secure a draw this also introduces
this idea and here black probably needs
to can switch back to this idea with the
draw completely crazy I mean I really
don't see a real people finding that
maybe maybe maybe I'm seeing it seeing
it wrong but rook t7 looks very tricky
to me to find if you look at other moves
justify for example this one look at
this check check and black was will go
with with Luke I for check check check
check check yeah funny right
okay but the thing is for practical game
taiyaki net it tells here 27 seconds I
think he even had less but even if this
is this is true he would need to make
five moves in 27 seconds which is not
here we're talking about the real game
where you need to move pieces they're
not with pre moving on the internet you
can do that but it's not not so easy to
play the moves out even and you need to
think of it at least a bit so he went
for Queenie 3g to get the Queen self
which is totally understandable um GTX
edge as mentioned seems to be a draw as
well but it would have demanded some
good moves by White Queen III however is
relatively easy now to handle take
stakes and now Bishop a form yeah this
night is obviously hanging black needs
to retreated and rook takes g5 getting a
pawn back yeah now we have a position
where black is one point up but it seems
that this should offer him very little
winning chances the problem is simply
that the night is a slightly clumsy
piece in the situation that it's not
really helping in any sort of defensive
way for the a pond y term has always
discount to play against the a pond and
in the next couple of moves which was
still plain and try and travel those
moves there was this trade happening and
Bishop see to ya in term another point
is that sometimes white can simply
capture on a five to get a get a very
dry end game and this is in fact what
happened rather quickly queen a king to
h6 look retweet it and now mama drf
decided to simply take away the night on
f5 it's them it's them not does this
does not look to not you kind of just
after I mentioned that
the night is a bit of a clumsy piece but
the thing is after this white is just
far too active with the rooks he set up
this position now we're both rooks
attack the apron black must defend like
that and this is just completely drawn
no check chance whatsoever of course
white is not allowing a rook trade this
might still be a draw but it's just much
easier this way if you always have this
pressure and black has absolutely no way
to make progress you can check just stay
with your rook Smoove the king there's
no way forward check check what sure
when they actually agree to a check
check check yeah yeah it's it's simply
nothing I mean they certainly wanted to
try on a hit yakkin yakkin with the
extra porn but there's nothing nothing
to do yeah a great fight very tactical
game I actually in my notes I had a
couple of more lines but it would have
probably confused the hell out of you so
I leave it leave it at that um if you
want to do to analyze bid to this game
bit more then here the position after f6
with Bishop f6 it's a really super
complicated interesting to to check out
it would have been very critical i
believe for kayaking to survive and now
in this time trouble that he that he was
in and it it was a very complicated
fight um yeah what does this mean for
the tournament standing yeah a draw as
mentioned the Sullivan it does not help
both play as much they would have needed
to win to seriously compete with arlen
still of course kayaking has in the next
round the white game against are not
with the wind there's always a
theoretical possibility to do some
things but this is now I mean it was
actually before a mandatory thing for
him to do if he wants to qualify what
mama dr office basically out of it as he
has the worst i break
compared to to Ireland yeah I hope you
enjoyed this this fascinating game
thanks for watching